public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
eric woerth secrétaire général des
républicains est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' afp les échos et
radio classique trois grandes questions
comme chaque semaine d'abord est-ce que
tout est acheté vraiment dans le bilan
de françois hollande qui va jusqu'à
affirmer qu'il à redresser la france
vous répondrai dans un instant à jean
francis pécresse
deuxième question pourquoi le programme
de nicolas sarkozy que vous soutenez est
il le meilleur vous le direz vous
répondrez à guillaume daudin enfin
troisième question est ce que la prière
est la primaire n'est pas déjà plié
parce que la prière n'est pas déjà dit
alain juppé continue de marquer des
points dans les tout derniers sondages
et là que vous répondrez à mickaël
szames s mais d'abord eric woerth une
question d'actualité
les policiers se disent tabou ils ont
manifesté la nuit dernière les images
sont spectaculaires sur les
champs-elysées pour exprimer leur
ras-le-bol
est ce que vous les soutenez oui je les
comprends il ya beaucoup de
d'exaspération beaucoup de colère il
faut voir qu'il ya 30% de plus en un an
de violences commises envers les
policiers c'est évidemment assez
insupportable je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
totalement les moyens de travailler qui
sont épuisés comme une arme d'ailleurs
il ya peu avec les policiers les
gendarmes aussi
et alors que là on soutient les
policiers j'ai envie de dire quand même
bien sûr dans le personnel politique
mais la question concernait la
manifestation en elle-même puisque la
hiérarchie policière et tout à l'heure
bernard cazeneuve au sénat a dénoncé un
manquement à la déontologie
ouais enfin la cgt peut faire n'importe
quoi dans des manifestations dans la loi
elle conneries cacher et finalement ils
peuvent réitérer les choses donc moi je
je je pense que dans l'état
de faty et d'exaspération de la société
française jeffrey t min je ferai
attention à cela
pas de problème c'est pas la même
élection ne renie pas la manifestation
enfin il faut quand même que nos
auditeurs sache que les policiers ils
ont droit de manifester alors il sert
peut-être faut-il qu'ils soient
autorisés que il ya des conditions ils
ont le droit de manifester mais pas dans
son droit à la grève ils n'ont pas le
droit d'un certain nombre de choses ils
ont le droit évidemment de manifester on
voit bien que c'est un mouvement
moi je crois que cette exaspération
cette montée de la violence envers les
policiers
cette perte d'autorité de l'état s'est
lassé de l'expression de cela quand on
est derrière cela pourquoi parce que
souvent la justice vous n'affrontez
acquis cette baisse de tarif découvert
la manita l'état au gouvernement
ceux qui nous gouvernent l'autorité elle
se symbolise quand la loi taubira a fait
a fait comprendre finalement aux gens
que que les délinquants étaient presque
la priorité du gouvernement puisqu'il
suffisait d'être condamné à cinq ans de
prison et ne pas les faire avec des
peines de substitution dans tous les
sens c'était un signal extrêmement fort
vis-à-vis de la délinquance est pas
vis-à-vis des victimes et les policiers
qui passent leur temps à tenter
d'essayer d'arrêter des gens ils se
retrouvent avec une chaîne pénale qui
s'occupe de choses inintéressantes ou
qui au contraire ne vont pas jusqu'au
bout des choses
le gouvernement répond déjà sur le plan
des effectifs policiers que ils ont
rétabli le un des policiers un peu
partout
contrairement à la droite qui avait
sabré dans les effectifs oui c'est
silence et skhira peut être en boucle la
vérité pas tout à fait cela par exemple
les gardes statiques
il y avait beaucoup de gardes statiques
on avait supprimé ses gardes statiques à
des questions c'est pas uniquement les
questions d'effectifs
il ya beaucoup de policiers en france
par rapport à d'autres pays donc la
question des la question là l'emploi
c'est l'émission c'est l'emploi de la
force
qu'est-ce qu'on leur fait faire et
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gardes
statiques y ont été rétablies et ses
gardes statiques alizés épuise elle
fatigue que ce soit les crs que ce soit
les policiers qui les mène dont s'est
pas complètement le métier pour faire de
la gare de mobiles lagarde dynamique et
pas le contraire
on voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
chaîne entre police justice et que cette
chaîne a été abîmée par la garde des
sceaux précédente et donc par le malheur
de menteur il
aujourd'hui oui elle en paye les frais
oui elles payent les frais dans un
moment où il fallait retirer l'autorité
on a détendu l'autorité les policiers ne
sont pas les seuls à être à bout à cran
avec les agressions violentes qui se
multiplient a notamment contre des
enseignants ces dernières heures dans le
val d'oise en seine saint denis des
profs ont été sauvagement agressés
est-ce que la situation est en train de
déraper bah oui a visiblement elle
dérape mais monsieur hollande de récolte
ce qu'il a semé c'est à dire du laxisme
et de la conséquence c'est de
l'incohérence
à force de considérer que l'autorité
doit être systématiquement du côté des
plus faibles et on qualifie parfois être
plus faibles tout simplement des
délinquants ça ne passe pas et c'est à
l'état de s'assurer
on voit bien que la campagne
présidentielle elle va porter beaucoup
là dessus c'est que on est à la croisée
des chemins selon la schl et les choses
et alors on aura du mal à le rattraper
et en tout cas on sait où ça se
terminera c'est-à-dire à l'extrême
droite
ou alors on reprend partout dans l'école
dans les codes ce qui s'est passé pour 7
proviseur pour ce pour ce professeur et
pour bien d'autres est tout à fait
insupportable on peut pas laisser cent
mille personnes sortir en décrochant bon
il faut bien réagir à tous la fois des
politiques en face on en propose les
années les républicains nicolas sarkozy
ses concurrents proposent un certain
nombre de politiques plus ou moins fort
en tout cas il n'y a pas de fatalité à
laisser la france
partir dans une vision laxisme devrait
changer donc autorité sécurité ce sera
l'objet de la deuxième partie de
l'émission tout à l'heure sur le
programme donc du candidat que vous
défendez pour la primaire nicolas
sarkozy met tout de suite c'est jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique que nous
accueillons l'épreuve de vérité
avec ray du classique et les échos
bonsoir jean françaix sans michel
bonsoir est immense alors françois
hollande comme on l'a vu hier sur le
site de florange appelle les siens être
fier du bilan de ce quinquennat est ce
que dans une certaine mesure il a pas
raison tout de même est ce que tout est
à jeter dans le bilan de françois
hollande
sûrement qu'en cinq ans tout n'est pas à
jeter on veut pourra faire un bilan a pu
regarder
il ya sûrement eu des éléments positifs
on peut pas être dans l'a4 qui
caricature tout le temps enfin quand on
regarde quand même l'ensemble du bilan
c'est ça qui compte
mais quand on regarde l'ensemble du
bilan c c'est au fond est-ce que la
france la progression ou pas est-ce
qu'on est encore plus heureux de vivre
en france cinq ans après est ce qu'on
est fiers de vivre dans notre pays
est ce qu'on a donné une vision et un
peu de perspectives à notre pays
à ces questions la réponse est non non
on est moins heureux qu'il ya cinq ans
on gagne on a bien du mal à rattraper
l'après crise en termes de pouvoir
d'achat les déficits publics s'améliore
à la vitesse de la tortue les
fonctionnaires et les le secteur privé
sont toujours en lutte les uns contre
les autres parce qu'il ya deux poids
deux mesures les systèmes le système
social n'est pas équilibré bref on a
perdu sur beaucoup de deux tableaux la
gagne et on ne repart pas et le chômage
le chômage il est totalement déjanté
fatalité au chômage de masse qui
aujourd'hui ne ne trouve pas de solution
et des points positifs quand même
l'investissement par le taux de marge
des entreprises est en train de
s'améliorer ce qui a pas un certain
nombre de choses aussi que vous auriez
aimé faire et qui ont été faites sous ce
quinquennat je pense au prélèvement à la
source des impôts paraît quand même nom
s'est enfin ça marche pas comme ça vous
êtes l'investissement
va mieux c'est vrai depuis mais depuis
l'année dernière il a été très mal
pendant trois quatre ans et un
quinquennat dans son ensemble c'est pas
parce que tout d'un coup ça va un peu
mieux à un moment donné quand ça a été
vraiment très très mal avant la vérité
c'est qu'on a reculé
c'est vrai dans le domaine des impôts la
surtaxation par tout le matraquage
fiscal
il sait il est passé au fond des
entreprises vers les ménages et tous les
ménages le savent très bien il n'y a pas
de cohérence une politique de réformes
c'est d'abord de la cohérence sur tous
les sujets on met en phase les outils
qualification les outils de production
la compétitivité du pays le contrat de
travail
rien de tout cela n'a existé on a changé
sans arrêt de politique bon ben voilà ça
ne peut pas fonctionner sur florange
fait d'être l'avocat du diable un peu
mais ce qu'il avait promis en 2012 a été
au fond tony puisque les 629 emploi les
629 salariés de florange ont tous été
manifestement reclasser ou sont partis à
la retraite et la filière froide
fonctionne encore
je conduis là bas il avait parlé de
politique industrielle les salariés
n'avaient pas compris tout à fait ça
enfin je l'interrogé l'est donc il
n'avait pas compris tout à fait cela
donc je suis un peu étonné de constater
avec l'orangé est un succès je sais pas
si c'est un échec
enfin le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
pas un succès demander à la députée
d'ailleurs de la circonscription
elle vous le dire les mêmes sorties du
gouvernement en partie pour pour cela
retire moi je pense que la vérité c'est
que françois hollande n'est plus on peut
les plus audibles
quel que soit ce qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui mais sur les tomber si bas
accor qui n'est plus audible pour un
président barack lui c'est quand même un
problème c'est quand même un tout petit
problème pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas
président on peut jurer ça pour un
président de l'apic c'est compliqué
n'est pas audible international
examinent lui demande la parole
justement vous pensez que cette unité de
leurs cela il a vécu prises il l'a prise
il s'est exprimé dans un livre étrange
et curieux il a revu beaucoup de vos
collègues pendant des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois il dit des trucs qui ne
sont absolument pas compatible avec ce
qu'il dit entre le privé et le public
on voit bien que l'on voit bien tout ça
et il peut se passer
j'en sais rien je suis à la gauche de le
dire en tout cas ils ne donnent pas
envie oui mon avis que est un échec il
peut tellement c'est un échec total non
jean sûr et je ne sais pas quel notre
intérêt à vous avez un avis alors lequel
je pense que je pense que ilaina enfin
il n'a qu'une koch aucune case pour être
candidat à la présidence de la
république
c'est un échec total aujourd'hui les
français doutent de sa compétence
être président de la république c'est
quand même un doute assez profond il n'a
pas respecté sa parole il a eu un
comportement le moins qu'on puisse dire
absolument étonnant donc je crois qu'il
faut tourner la page
budget 2010 est il est examiné à partir
d'aujourd'hui à l'assemblée ce moment
est-ce que voilà est-ce que ce budget
2010 est c'est un boulet pour la
prochaine majorité que vous souhaitez
être ou et oui oui parce que bah oui
parce que il ya d'abord ce boulet ce
monsieur budget pardon il est assez
factuel factice et ça veut pas dire
grand-chose d'examiner un budget comme
ça parce que samedi électoral totalement
électoralistes construit autour de
l'élection présidentielle il ya plein de
cadeaux ce budget il crée des charges
supplémentaires pour l'année 2010 huit
ans voit combien c'est difficile à dire
mais c'est au moins une dizaine de
milliards d'euros
donc ces charges elles vont elles sont
repoussés un peu comme de la poussière
sous le tapis et elles viendront obérer
le travail de la future majorité dont 2
budget c'est juillet le vrai budget
c'est juillet 2010 est étonnamment on a
déplacé l'exercice budgétaire de du mois
d'octobre ou novembre au mois de juillet
c'est soit nous sommes de pouvoir et
nous retravaillons ce budget en fonction
des propositions d du candidat qui sera
élu soit nous ne sommes pas au pouvoir
et donc si ces socialistes ils remettent
decker ce budget qui est dans des
hypothèses macroéconomiques assez
surréaliste et c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le haut comité aux finances
publiques et deuxième point pousse loin
un certain nombre de dépenses qui
concerne pourtant l'exercice à venir et
anticipe sur des recettes à venir tant
qu'on aura moins de recettes en 2018
qu'on devrait en avoir on aura plus de
dépenses qu'on devrait en avoir
l'état reste lui même d'ailleurs dans un
déficit important et la dette continuent
à progresser
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
c'est quand même pas très excitant si
pression sur notre dame des landes le
premier ministre manuel valls a
réaffirmé sa volonté de les évacuer par
la force s'il le faut est ce que ça vous
rassure est ce que vous êtes très
favorable à ce que ce soit fait dans les
jours à venir
la raison demain s'il veut enfin il a
raison et ils sont allés au bout des
voies de droit déjà ça prend beaucoup de
temps il est inacceptable et des gens
venus tous les pays d'ailleurs ces gens
qui en rien à faire à cet endroit là et
qui ne sont juges des activistes
politiques qui prônent la violence
il faut qu'ils dégagent du terrain 7 cet
équipement était considéré comme utile
il faut le faire puisqu'il était
considéré comme et il a eu des années
des années d'études
donc il faut le faire et il doit avoir
le débat ségolène royal elle enfourche
tout les sujets les plus démagogiques lé
ministre des transports elle ne fait
rien dans ce domaine là on se demande
enfin j'ai jamais vu un ministre ne pas
occuper ses fonctions à les ministres
des transports en a jamais vu parce que
c'est un sujet trop difficile pour elle
et puis elle essayait d'aller briller
sur des plateaux pour essayer de signer
l'accord 21 dont elle n'est absolument
pas responsables donc il ya un moment
donné
moi je ne comprends pas qu'elle soit au
gouvernement monsieur hollande il
devrait séparer des milices qui dit le
contraire d'un autre ministre qui va
dans le sens contraire de l'action du
gouvernement la présente comme la
vice-présidente par était là
si la vice présidente c'est à dire le
contraire du président très bien mais si
le président dit à des journalistes que
ça n'ira pas jusqu'au bout si j'ai bien
compris dans le loyer mais j'ai en tout
cas non démissionner je n'ai pas pas
quelqu'un qui doit démissionner le chef
du gouvernement j'ai vu gouvernement il
doit mettre de la cohérence dans son
gouvernement et de lui dire t'es pas
d'accord tu t'en vas
mais comme le chef de l'état lui-même a
mis en cause dans son bouquin de vos
deux confrères il a mis en cause
semble-t-il cet équipement on se demande
ce que pense le gouvernement mais c'est
pas le sujet notre dame des landes c'est
vrai sur tous les sujets merci beaucoup
jean francis et maintenant c'est
guillaume daudin notre confrère de l'
agence france-presse qui arrive pour la
deuxième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
vous avez choisi nicolas sarkozy dans la
primaire vous allez nous dire peut-être
pourquoi tout simplement son programme
est le meilleur pour vous qu'est ce qui
est peut-être l'élément clé qui vous
fait dire que d'abord c'est d'abord
aussi une question de tempérament je
crois que nicolas sarkozy il était
président de la république et que c'est
pas si mal de pouvoir bénéficier de
l'expérience d'un président la réplique
certains disent ah bah non c'est pas
bien vous pas revoir les gens qu'est ce
que c'est que ça on n'a pas envie de
refaire le casting ok mais enfin je
pense qu'au contraire c'est une chance
d'avoir quelqu'un qui refait un parcours
qui mon dieu se prend un nombre de coups
considérables qui ne se prennent pas les
autres il ne prend pas une très
tranquille pour laisser compagnie de
renaud cyr à lui oui enfin la campagne
des compétiteurs de nicolas sarkozy elle
est super tranquille donc la campagne de
sarkozy par contre c'est autre chose on
lui fait passer un certain nombre
d'épreuves et finalement pourquoi pas
mais un certain nombre d'épreuves
extrêmement difficile donc il a le
talent pour ça il a l'énergie pour ça il
a l'expérience pour sa part ailleurs il
a un projet qui était extrêmement
cohérent et très complet aussi à la fois
sur le plan économique en essayant
d'équilibrer parce que je pense qu'il
faut mettre beaucoup sur la
compétitivité des entreprises
il le feu 34 milliards d'euros c'est ici
le confiseur etc etc
mais il le fait aussi sur l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est un sujet qu'on a
on a discuté évidemment ensemble ils
estiment et je pense qu'il a raison
j'ai cette expérience aussi c'est qu'il
faut quand même c'est très difficile de
dire aux français qu'ils ont été quand
même matraquer fiscalement les ménages
confond on veut réduire les impôts mais
pas pour ceux qui ont vu leurs impôts
augmenter
il est assez compliqué expliqué il faut
beaucoup de cohérence si c'est pas
cohérent
si vous dites des trucs qui sont
contradictoires alors l'effort que vous
demandez eh bien il n'est pas à mener ou
en tout cas il est si mal perçu qu'il ya
des blocages je prends l'exemple de la
tva ça oppose nicolas sarkozy à ses
compétiteurs
françois fillon comme alain juppé
propose des augmentations de tva c'est
assez compliqué de dire à nos
concitoyens
on arrive on veut baisser les impôts
parce que les impôts ont été trop
fortement augmenté mais vous inquiétez
pas on augmente la tva ça ces contrats
des débats internes au sein de cette
primaire vu de l'extérieur vu de la
gauche vu je vais même vous citer alain
madelin ancien ministre de l'économie de
deux votes contre et libéral ont joint
il disait au point le programme des
candidats à la primaire c'est une
caricature du libéralisme qui apparaît
comme une purge patronale vous pensez je
ne veux pas ce que ça veut dire la
madeleine il est d'abord pas qualifié
pour ce il était ministre pendant trois
mois et il est totalement échoué
donc c'est pas c'est pas le sujet je
pense que le sujet c'est ça oui mais le
débat il était de bonne qualité
est ce qu'il ya une tolérance vous nous
dites est ce que finalement est ce qu'on
est capable de proposer des trucs précis
où est-ce qu'on veut créer créer des
plans sur la comète
on propose des choses précises chaque
candidat dit des choses précises donc
ces choses dans le domaine de l'économie
on a l'habitude de dire ouais mais ils
pensent tous la même chose pas tout à
fait le programme de dessin peut en
parler mais il ya un certain nombre
d'observateurs vos opposants aussi
évidemment qui trouve que c'est un
absolu remède de cheval pour l'économie
française
non parce que si vous considérez que les
communes françaises elles marchent bien
bas faut me le dire et puis il faut
surtout faire une dépêche tout de suite
mais je pense que et non plusieurs
méthodes pour un vrai nom je vois pas
faire partie je crois pas je pense qu'il
n'y a pas une multitude de il faut faire
ce qu est ce qui a marché dans d'autres
pays
on dit toujours les allemands les
allemands formidable les anglais à un
moment donné formidable regardez ils ont
aujourd'hui récupérer une économie
plutôt en bonne santé bah oui mais ils
sont passés par des
10 preuve que nous nous sommes au fond
exonérait d'ailleurs droite et gauche
compris nicolas sarkozy propose alors
ses voeux c'est vous le spécialiste à la
fois des chiffres de nicolas sarkozy et
l'ancien ministre du budget il propose
100 milliards d'euros d'économies sur
les dépenses de l'état
ouais on est on est à combien
actuellement dépenses de l'état on est à
dans le budget actuel on est à autour de
350 pages entières dont un tiers de
dépens des 100 milliards sur l'ensemble
de la sphère publique
d'accord donc c'est pas à 100 milliards
sur été assistant milliards sur
l'ensemble de la sphère publique
mais il ya l'état la sécurité sociale et
les collectivités locales c'est à dire
sur une dépense qui est de l'ordre de
1250 milliards d'euros corps donc c'est
on va dire un douzième à ce niveau là on
n'est plus tellement déjà dans le
rabotage journée il financera durable
voilà alors on a toujours fait nous on a
fait la fille du ragot qui sait pas du
rabot c'est quoi alors dit changement de
politique c'est des réformes
structurelles ces décodeurs honda en
dise est structurel
je sais pas il faut baisser la dépense
publique c'est l'intérêt national c'est
l'intérêt du pays il faut baisser la
dépense julie elle est aujourd'hui à 56
ou 57 % de fibres selon qu'on calcule
avec les crédits d'impôt pas les crédits
d'impôts mais c'est trop ll et les pays
de l'union européenne et la zone euro il
tourne à moins de 50
donc on voit bien qu'on peut pas avec un
tel boulet alors ce boulet ça devient
une bouée de sauvetage
quand il une grande crise ça a été le
cas on a plongé un peu moins et puis on
avait un bon président de la république
quand on a un mauvais président de la
république et plus debout et de sauver
plus de crise
cette ça devient un handicap majeur ça
vous entraîne vers le fond il ya moins
de consommation
il ya moins d'investissement pour
relancer l'investissement et la
consommation faut prendre moins d'argent
aux français aux entreprises françaises
et aux ménages français et ça passe par
une réduction de la dépense dont +11
nicolas sarkozy comme ses adversaires à
là où ses concurrents à la primaire de
la droite c'est des pelletées de
fonctionnaires en moins nicolas sarkozy
ces trois irait pas des pelletées c'est
pas sympa pour les fonctionnaires ces
reports s'il ya trop de fonctionnaires
voilà il ya trop de fonctionnaires en
france et pas assez bien payé donc on
avait commencé à les réduire on a fait
150 milles sur l'état les collectivités
locales ont compensé la chose
malheureusement mais les faits sont là
dans un moment où voilà il ya quelques
et des craintes ou même de la
mondialisation fait des choses
difficile contre us qui sont pas dans
une demande de plus de services publics
et la réforme c'est l'espoir réformer
c'est l'espoir ne rien faire c'est le
chômage
il faut redresser notre pays il faut
aller au bout des réformes des réformes
dans le cadre de fonctionnement bancal
de notre pacte social moi je suis pas en
train de dire qu'il faut briser faire
table rase
françois hollande manuel valls encore
aujourd'hui devant les parlementaires du
métal jaune qui dit le programme commun
la droite va mettre à bas notre modèle
social
oui ou un non ce sont des paroles
politiques qui veulent rien dire mettre
à bas le modèle social français c'est 6
millions de chômeurs mettra balle modèle
social français
ces petites retraites partout mettra
balle modèle social français
c'est de faire que les jeunes il
considère que l'avenir il est en dehors
de france et ça c'est pas nicolas
sarkozy
ça c'est françois hollande manuel valls
monsieur ayrault et plein d'autres donc
il ya quand même des limites à
l'hypocrisie
il ya une hypocrisie socialiste
aujourd'hui qui est totalement
insupportable qui est insupportable
donc on doit revenir à quelque chose de
sain quelque chose de sérieux
faire en sorte que la france reste la
france qu'on soit toujours solidaires
les uns des autres mais dans des
conditions de responsabilité je crois à
la responsabilité collective mais je
crois surtout à la responsabilité
individuelle et quand il ya trop
responsabilité collective alors tout le
monde s'exonère de sa rentabilité en
question pas les séries et mickaël
isabey ce qui arrive maintenant dans la
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir michel bonsoir alors à ce qu'un
gps déjà gagner cette primaire serait ce
que c'est plié
alors non enfin je vous hésitez enfin je
suis ici parce que je le lis et comment
je vais répondre à ça la primaire est
dans un mois les sondages certains
sondages sont en faveur d'alain juppé au
quai les sondages eric va couiner pop 41
pour alain juppé au premier tour 61 39
au deuxième tour l'écart plus les jours
arrivent et pourrir en dit vous verrez
ça sera et vous verrez que ramener chez
vous verrez qu'il y aura des surprises
balle jour de l'élection
et d'ailleurs ces sondages
systématiquement c'est sur l'ensemble de
la population et sus une population qui
s'estiment aller voter puis à départ de
gauche les départs de tous quand vous
regardez le coeur de l'électorat de la
primaire de droite et du centre - le
choeur de nicolas sarkozy est
systématiquement vainqueur donc on verra
on verra bien moi je pense qu'il faut
maintenant il faut continuer la campagne
telle qu'elle est il faut dire aux
français ce que nous souhaitons pour le
pays nicolas sarkozy doit le faire les
autres candidats doivent le faire et
puis in fine et les français ils
voteront les français de droite et les
français du centre ils voteront
est ce que vous n'avez pas les autres
est ce que vous êtes très peu de malice
de la quasi non je suis moi j'ai aucune
inquiétude je peux vous assurer que je
suis extrêmement zen on maintient la
campagne allait elle est puissante
il est partout sur le terrain il ya du
monde dans toutes les salles plus de
monde que pour quiconque je n'ai aucune
inquiétude
la qualité de ces propositions est fort
tout ça ce se verra moi j'ai pas
d'adversaire dans cette dans cette
campagne je jouerai pour le vainqueur de
toute façon sans état d'âme mais je
soutiendrai le vainqueur dès le soir du
second tour et je ferai sa campagne
évidence et les règles de la primaire
est gelée elles sont extrêmement
importantes je n'ai aucune question là
dessus je dis simplement que je pense
que nikos a aidé nicolas sarkozy est le
meilleur candidat
sauf que évidemment comme il est la
cible de tout le monde c'est nettement
plus simple je pense que la campagne de
tous les autres candidats est une
campagne a si simple au fond il ya
jamais de coup personne ne dit jamais
rien donc chacun y va de sa petite cette
petite campagne est d'accord nicolas
sarkozy est plus compliqué anti sarkozy
est plus compliqué oui il ya beaucoup de
ça sarkozy est une mini cible au fond et
les acides de tout le monde fait la
cible des médias 0
absolument tout le monde dès qu'il dit
quelque chose s'il bat un mouvement de
cl c'est pas comme ça qu'il fallait
faire il fallait battre l'autre cible
tout et tout est très très analysé bon
on verra vous leviez finissait beaucoup
là quand même parce que c'est la vérité
et si la vérité donc on verra bien on
verra bien c'est une campagne puissante
cette campagne puissante elle portera
ses fruits moi j'ai pas de doute là
dessus
alors vous avez dit il ya un instant que
vous appelez les électeurs de droite et
du centre a voté j'ai bien compris que
vous avez oublié ceux de gauche aillent
n'ont pas leur place dans cette primaire
écouter ce que dit alain juppé au sujet
de la participation éventuelle ou
confirmés selon certains sondages 10%
dit-on d'électeurs de gauche à la
primaire de droite et du centre nous
avons voulu des primaires ouvertes il
faut l'assumer
je vois d'ailleurs que nicolas sarkozy
fait mieux que moi dans l'électorat du
front national nous disent qu'on va
interdire j permis la levée n'a pas fait
appel aux électeurs du front national
j'ai pas fait appel aux électeurs de
gauche qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire non mais fait appel aux
électeurs de la droite et du centre
socialise les électeurs déçus du
hollandisme sont souvent des électeurs
déçus du sarkozysme si monsieur kouchner
vient voter par exemple en disant j'ai
été ministre de nicolas sarkozy
qu'est ce qu'on va faire alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait les électeurs du lait
des électeurs déçus du sarkozysme sont
des électeurs déçus du gouvernement dans
son ensemble
un jeu tout le monde a été ministre et
ministre est très important à tous les
moments donc je vraiment c'est important
à dire le quinquennat il est propriété
de tous ceux qui ont participé personne
n'est parti en claquant la porte ce
serait différent
personne n'est parti en claquant la
porte donc il ya je pense sur le
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy une
cohérence
donc je non je pense que je pense qu'il
ya des appels du pied
voilà globalement il ya des appels du
pied sur les électeurs de gauche en
disant vous êtes déçu par françois
hollande
venez donc voté pour nous d'ailleurs
qu'importe venez voter pour nous à
l'élection primaire peut être que vous
voterez pour la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle elle même parce que c'est
ça qui va se passer
moal électeurs de gauche qui décide
d'être à droite il a sa place dans la
primaire je sais pas de problème il est
plus à gauche il dit à droite jusqu'au
village
ah oui faut qu'il reste il faut qu'ils
viennent de gauche n'a pas à interférer
dans la primaire de la droite comme
électeurs de droite
il n'a pas interféré dans la primaire de
la gauche parce que dans ce cas là il
faut pas faire de primaire dans ce cas
là ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
vie fier la primaire est donc de vicié
de vicier les résultats de roche et
éventuellement j'ai pas dit ça et de vue
est devenue ce qu'elle est c'est moi
laissez moi et de vicier l'élection
présidentielle elle même donc il faut
faire très attention à ça si nous
faisons il faut de la déontologie dans
l'élection primaire et c'est pas un
problème la haute autorité aux autorités
elles mécanique
s'ils vont sur la politique moi j'ai vu
ça j'ai quand même vu d d d d d d
interview dans libération
c'est une drôle d'idée c'est oui j'aime
beaucoup jean pierre raffarin c'est un
ami c'est un ami personnel
mais faire une interview dans libération
c'est signé ça veut dire simplement fait
un appel du pied à l'électorat de gauche
libération
un journal de gauche qui se revendique à
gauche donc ça ne va pas il fait si les
électeurs de gauche vont voter à la
primaire est ce que la primaire est
faussé mais moi je veux
aucun enseignement parce que si vous
l'aimez à tirer pour dire on va
contester le résultat de la génération
moi je ne contesterai pas le résultat de
la primaire parce que dans ce cas là non
je ne contesterai pas fait détesterait
pas vous mais moi je voulais relais même
d'accrocs allait bientôt jeudi sur je ne
tire pas de conséquence de ce que je dis
mais je tire le sonel de la sonnette
d'alarmé pour que ça ne se passe pas
proche de françois hollande ont fait
sortir un petit papier en tout cas un
petit fascicule dans lequel il est
marqué tout ce qu'il pense qu'en mal
d'alain juppé sur son programme
économique se sont passé judiciaire
le but c'est de les décourager d'aller
voter à la primaire de droite c'est
l'alliance de circonstance et aucune
alliance avec françois hollande parce
que ça c'est franchement ça peut vous
tirer vers le bas à une alliance avec
françois hollande ce sera vraiment
absolument dramatique
françois hollande est un président
stagiaires on n'en veut plus personne
n'en veut plus
donc il faut à cette primaire elle est
sérieuse et moi je demande qu'on y
réponde
sérieusement si un électeur considèrent
qu'ils signent la charte de la primaire
on aurait dû faire une charte d'ailleurs
plus longue qui cite sept chars pour
dire je suis un électeur de droite c'est
ça que ça veut dire
7 je suis un électeur de droite et du
centre la profession si c'est si c'est
le cas et si le type ou là où la dame
signe cela c'est à dire qu elle le jure
et donc si elle ne fait pas ce qu'elle
est par jour donc attention à cela
c'est très important pour la qualité la
primaire notre primaire doit pas nous
échapper
on doit pas voler cette primaire aux
électeurs de la droite et du centre je
ne dis que cela me suis même étonnée
d'avoir à le dire pour tout vous dire je
suis même étonné et rigueur que
justement nicolas sarkozy vous a rendu
hommage lors de ce premier débat des
primaires il a évoqué votre non lieu
dans l'enquêté de la vente de
l'hippodrome de compiègne aujourd'hui on
apprend que l'encours plutôt si
l'affairé bettencourt mettant de la
route avec affaire bettencourt le nom de
je pense à un non lieu puisque cette
affaire de l'hippodrome de compiègne
est elle relancée la cour d'appel
demande la reprise de de l'anc est votre
réaction
il ya déjà eu deux instructions une
quête duré quatre ans à la cour de
justice est rendue cassation c'est les
mêmes magistrats qui a conclu à un
non-lieu concernant c'était la partie
ministérielle tout a été vu et regardez
ce n'est pas une affaire c'est un
dossier
alors y'a pas d'avoir gardé pour du
compte il ya un dossier
c'est une bagarre entre administrations
mes collaborateurs était haute et j'ai
emmené par un syndicat de gauche
d'ailleurs de l'eau nf qui aiment les
arbres comme on doit les aimer dans le
désert et 7
c'est idiot et et il ya eu un non lieu
prononcé par le juge d'instruction après
3 ans et un non lieu confirmé par le
parquet il ya eu un appel de ce non-lieu
ce non-lieu le la chambre d'instruction
a considéré qu'il fallait à supplément
d'instruction il ya supplément madrigaux
c'est quoi c'est bien ça fait quatre ans
qu'on est sur ce sujet c'est une honte
je vais vous le dire et donc il c'est
une affiche aujourd'hui je me pose
beaucoup de questions en tout cas une
persécution judiciaire là dessus sur ce
sujet c'est pas un sujet il n'y a pas de
sujet l'hippodrome de compiègne ça
n'existe pas tu as un bon dossier pour
l'état que maintenant la justice en
train de transformer en un mauvais
dossier pour l'état une aimable secourus
tandis que cela à faire ses jeux sur
vige on n'a pas réussi à atteindre on
veut attendre mes collaborateurs c'est
vraiment pas bien
merci à vous merci michael merci à tous
la semaine prochaine c'est michel sapin
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances qui sera à votre place qui sera
notre invité devant soir a très vite